just went through this with my daughter
this kid is just very much like i do
what i want and the world is
very different place than
when i was a kid you know i do what i
want could be like i'm gonna experiment
with drugs you'd live now there could be
a grain of fentanyl on whatever the hell
that is and it's like
it's over it's finished on my deathbed
all i need to know for myself lou is
that i dotted the eyes and i crossed the
t's and i did the best that i could do
for you and beyond this you want to go
around me you're going to win
like you're working 24 7 to beat me like
i'm going to do my best to make sure you
don't get physically hurt you don't
unintentionally hurt someone else and
i'm going to be good with that dude but
the minute i like kind of gave up not on
her but on trying to control the grades
went from f's and d's to a's and b's i'm
not the perfect mother
by 80 means and things are not going to
be perfect at some point you have to let
go you have to you have no choice